(screams)
(Russian accordion music)
- It doesn't smell terrible,
but it looks weird as hell.
- It definitely smells kinda coleslaw-y.
- Oh no!
(laughs)
- It's like fish with
purple mayonnaise on top.
- It tastes like the ocean.
- I'm into this.
- It has a very dirt-like aftertaste.
Which I like dirt, I ate dirt growing up.
- The Russians go to space.
I wonder if they make the
astronauts eat that (beep).
Smells normal, smells bologna-ish.
- This is the color of the zombies
on The Walking Dead<i/>.
- I've never had bologna.
(hums)
- I've had bologna.
- I'd say this tastes like
purchasing a Dell computer,
just no joy.
- It doesn't really taste like anything.
- I actually like it to be honest.
- Natasha, can I have your bologna?
- No, only if you give me
your fish covered in beets.
- Oh, that's so pickled.
- This is tough, this is so hard.
- It's so wet.
- Thanks.
- Oh, that's a lot of flavor, wow.
- The garlicky-ness of it
helped me get through it.
- This tastes like someone
threw acid on my grandmother.
- I would blend that and drink it.
- I like it so much!
- You are wrong.
- (laughs) Look at it jiggle.
- The meat smells good, but why?
- I don't know if I can do this.
- Uh-uh.
- The taste is fine.
It tastes like chicken pot pie,
whatever, it's the texture.
- Oh my God, this is so gross.
- You brought us Tetris,
but you also brought us this,
so we're kinda back at zero.
- This is what you
would eat at the Capitol
of The Hunger Games.
(screams)
- Wait a second.
- [Woman] What?
- This is really, really weird.
I'm not getting any smell at all.
- Why must you do this to me?
- This is already going horribly wrong.
(indistinct talking)
- It's so tough.
- It's so salty.
- All right, you're gonna kill me.
I think I'm into it.
- If I had to choose between
the meat Jello and this,
I would take 20 of these.
- As far as meat-related items,
this might be the best maybe.
- I would say this is probably
the best thing that we've had today.
- Thumbs up, A+.
More pickled tomatoes.
We need more pickled
tomatoes in our lives.
We really do.
- [Man In Hat] We need
to get more creative
with our pickling in general.
- I don't know why we
don't pickle everything.
I love pickling.